Former Japanese prime minister Shinzo Abe has died...
...after he was shot while delivering a rally speech...
...in Nara Prefecture in western Japan.
This was confirmed by Liberal Democratic Party officials to local media.
The 67-year-old was Japan's longest serving prime minister,...
...who served two stints in office.
Reports say Mr. Abe was shot on the left side of his chest...
...and apparently also in the neck.
He was taken by an ambulance to a medical evacuation helicopter...
...and then transported to Nara Medical University Hospital.
Earlier today, Prime Minister Fumio Kishida...
...condemned the barbaric attack,...
...which he said was unforgivable and would not be tolerated.